on va mettre en parler consommation avec
vous un philippe fleuret bonjour bonsoir
pardon vous êtes président du ufc que
choisir de la région de versailles alors
ya un projet de loi qui est passée
presque inaperçue jean vigué en tout cas
qui a été votée très rapidement par les
députés c'est le projet de loi sans
l'arrêt à la consommation et puis
d'abord on va commencer tout d'abord par
un chiffre avant de débuter cet
entretien c'est le chiffre du jour
72,6 france affiche 60 donc c'est le nom
d' articles du texte alors on se dit que
c'est quand même très important 72
article pour un texte sur la
consommation on va peut être content oui
c'est année c'est très important oui
bien sûr alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que dans ce texte il ya plusieurs choses
il ya une mesure emblématique qui
concerne l'action du groupe
l'introduction de l'action de groupe en
france on va en parler parce
qu'effectivement c'était même article du
projet de loi l'a310 mais ça veut dire
quoi il ya 72 articles comme ça ça veut
dire qu'il ya un vrai manque mans pour
en tout cas que les fédérations
consommateurs avec des grandes demandes
a précisé il a demandé à ses seuls
consommateurs certes mais s'ils
voulaient en même temps aussi il s'agit
d'introduire dans le droit français des
décisions de jurisprudence c'est une
mise à jour en fait les pies
d'introduire aussi des dispositions des
directives européennes donc dans le
droit français voilà donc il ya trois
sources différentes alors effectivement
vous l'avez parle parlé de son projet
phare c'est des actions de groupe class
action plutôt l'économie nie tout on les
connaît plutôt comme ça aux états unis
et là ça va être les actions de groupe à
la française à d'abord est-ce qu'on peut
rappeler ce que sont que des actions
groupe ont sans doute un peu moins voilà
donc c'est un nouveau droit pour les
consommateurs ce droit permet à un
consommateur victime d'un préjudice
d'obtenir réparation de ce préjudice
sans a tenté une action individuelle
c'est à dire qu'il passera par
l'intermédiaire d'une association de
consommateurs agréées pour obtenir
réparation de son préjudice et ça
c'était une demande
l'ancien v10
est content de sa
saison malgré tout il ya des petites bon
tout n'est pas tout ce que vous
demandiez au ticket n'a pas été obtenu
tout ce qu'on demandait de fête et
obtenu bon ceci dit on est satisfait
donc sur l'introduction de ce nouveau
droit pour les consommateurs il ya
certaines réserves bien sûr donc on va
avoir l'occasion du débat parlementaire
comment tout cela va se régler
bon vous savez que il ya deux domaines
qui sont exclues la loi c'est le domaine
médical sur tout ce qui est des grands
procès qu'on connaît actuellement donc
sont équipés les protéger bébé aux
médias lors par exemple voilà et puis
tous les litiges qui sont issus de
du droit de l'environnement par exemple
une marée noire par exemple j'ai envie
de dire c'est comme important c'est pas
des petits d'exclusion sur des domaines
quand même oui bien sûr bien sûr oui
il faut
les réseaux pour nous le serons le soin
bien sûr bon ceci tout espoir n'est pas
perdu si vous laisser dire que le
ministre benoît hamon a souhaité
commencer le puits d'amont on va dire et
moi j'entends à l'occasion du débat que
d'autres ministres d'hier le ministre de
l'environnement ome la santé sont prêts
à avoir une introduction de ces droits
une prochaine audience donc tout n'est
pas fini effectivement la mise à la
consommation nous avons à préciser que
l'action de groupe pourrait être étendue
à noël prochain à l'occasion d'autres
textes et marisol touraine a misé la
santé c'est ce bateau là ministre de
l'environnement fedimmo pourrait étudier
ça d'exactement de très près puisque le
le vote solennel internationale c'est
mercredi 3 juillet puis ensuite ça va
passer au sénat c'est un concours en mi
juillet donc ça pourrait éventuellement
évoluer il ya aussi d'autres choses qui
dans ses actions groupe qui
effectivement c'est très positif mais il
ya aussi d'autres choses qui vous
inquiète impôts ou en tout cas notamment
sur les avances de frais oui alors c'est
ça nous avons des réserves de trois
natures c'est premièrement c'est le
financement de l'action parce que il
faut engager des sommes très importantes
il faut savoir que dans des actions
précédentes
c'est choisir les rejets des frais à
hauteur de près de cinq cent mille euros
donc il ya très peu de social que ce
moteur qui sont capables d'engager des
frais comme ça veut dire quoi savoir que
les consommateurs vont forcément se
tourner vers des associations d'avoir
une demande nationale pour la société
comprend aussi je sais pas encore tous
savaient pas encore figé c'est celle de
rencontrer entre associations justement
le conciliateur oui il ya toujours des
échanges entre nous bien sûr qu'on bien
sûr vous parlez de lien commun
6 puis on verra tout ça on verra comment
tout ça donc il ya des des crédits qui
doivent être publiées pour préciser les
conditions d'introduction des actions
donc un problème donc de financement un
problème de liquidation parce que la
liquidation des indemnités d'un cadre
d'une condamnation en justice d'une
entreprise ou d'un groupe d'entreprises
actuellement donc ce sont les
associations de consommateurs qui
devrait répartir l'indemnité liquider
les invités donc ça c'est pas trop le
rôle des socios ce moteur nous ont
préféré un mandataire en justice et puis
la troisième chose c'est la publicité
dans le texte initial il est prévu que
la publicité soit faite à l'issue de
l'épuisement de tous les recours de
droit et donc on sait qu'en france
justice et non oui on va dire ça comme
ça et donc avant que ça passe en appel
en cassation des allers retours tout
cela on peut avoir plusieurs années est
bien évident qu'un consommateur plus de
moyens souvent de faire la preuve il
aurait pu sans ticket de caisse il
rappelé sa facture reliée donc ça ce
n'est qu'un de nous ce qu'on
souhaiterait celui-ci soit faite des
daims connaissance du premier jugement
c'est ce qu'on souhaiterait qu'elle
action vous pouvez faire maintenant
c'est à dire aller revoir les députés
pour faire du bien sûr me loving entre
guillemets on fait bien sûr j'espère
m'en fous des sénateurs oui c'est sûr
c'est ce que l'on fait alors
on se reverra peut-être
en tout cas nous nous sommes allés du
côté des rues de saint quentin en
yvelines pour demander aux habitants ce
qui pensait justement de ces actions de
groupe on va écouter les réponses et
saint quentinois
ben c'est bien c'est mutualiser des
problématiques pour trouver des
solutions communes c'est très bien pour
que l'action en justice réussissent oui
plus on est mieux c'est que je pense et
je dirais il ya plus d'idées aussi
puisque chaque personne a des idées
différentes donc voilà bah oui c'est une
bonne initiative effectivement parce que
c'est plus dans les groupes et puis en
plus on gagne n'est ce pas donc c'est
comme partout tous à l'eau n'y arrive
pas à plusieurs on y arrive donc je
crois qu'il vaut mieux oui c'est pas mal
je pense que c'est une bonne chose pour
défendre le consommateur
individuellement un consommateur qui se
sent lésé pour une raison pour une autre
n'osera pas forcément a tenté une
démarche alors que les actions de groupe
faciliteront ce genre de
démarches et de défense du consommateur
je pense
voilà alors du coup ce qu'on entend des
consommateurs c'est que évidemment plus
on est fort
finalement ils vous suivent j'aurais
l'envié aussi sur d'autres mesures qui
ont été adoptées à l'occasion de cette
loi sur la consommation celle et rémy
qui seront aujourd'hui demain plus
encadré oui à l'isf action alors on
pense qu'un biomédicale de fidélité d'un
crédit revolving dans lequel dévoile
agences en ligne de crédit renouvelable
voilà donc il y avait déjà eu une
première avancée avec la loi lagarde il
ya trois ans maintenant de cela et là
donc il y aura l'obligation pour les
sociétés de crédit de proposer un crédit
classique sur un crédit amortissable des
anneaux shan et cadre supérieur à 1000
euros et non pas réservé uniquement la
publicité ou la l'information sur les
crédits renouvelables à benoît hamon a
dit qu'il était très fier de cette
mesure sur les crédits vous suivez là
dessus c'est vraiment une vraie avancée
parce que vous avez fêté en parler de la
des premiers pas qui avait été fait par
christine lagarde il ya trois ans alors
là c'est vraiment une vraie avancée
c'est du neuf ans et oui donc parce que
vous savez que bon en définitive c'est
le survêtement en france qui pose
problème donc on verra bien alors il ya
un débat aussi sur le fichier sauvé le
fichier positif serre sur le fichier de
crédits visés et l'accès donc pour les
organismes
on est réservée s'ils voulaient parce
qu'il a été introduit en belgique et on
voit que le surendettement n'a pas
diminué pour autant il s'est accru pour
passer à s'enregistrer qui permet de
recenser les personnes qui ont contracté
des crédits sur l'ancienne été vu comme
ça ça a l'air plutôt positif oui oui
c'est la positif mais ceci dit si vous
voulez le fichier non enfin d'un data
initial il prévoyait le recensement de
tous les détenteurs de crédit et sa
cette affiche est énorme qui coûterait
très cher à établir voyez donc il faut
voir aussi le coup une époque on doit
faire des économies aussi il faut
s'interroger sur cela il vacille et
avait d'ailleurs admis un avis négatif
ou des réserves sur ce point là donc non
ce que l'on pense ce qui est important
c'est que le crédit classique c'est avec
mozilla menti sable se reposer dans tous
les cas quelle publicité soit faite et
que les cartes de crédit le ministre en
a parlé aussi de cela que les caps sauvé
les cartes de fidélité vous savez vous
avez des points soit vraiment dissocier
les cartes de crédit donc ça c'est
plutôt positif un petit mot sur les
assurances il sera possible de résilier
des contrats d'assurance notamment ce
qu'on appelle les assurances affinitaire
notamment pour les portables et
appareils électroménagers à tout moment
après une première année d'engagement
oui sont déjà graves bien sûr et cela
parce que vous savez souvent les gens
étaient un peu idiot nier de ses
engagements alors si vous ratez la date
échéance à vous et ça repart encore pour
un an donc non ça c'est vraiment un
progrès c'est sur un petit mot 660
partie qu'on va pas tous les noms faire
mes animaux faire la restauration
l'appellation fait maison pour des
produits qui sont oui pour les produits
qui sont cuisinés à partir de matières
brutes sur place dans l'équipe et ça
aussi c'est une vraie transparence pour
le consommateur qui voit le travail des
produits soi disant fait maison
voilà donc un objectif de la loi aussi
c'est accroître la transparence donc et
la formation au profit des consommateurs
donc ça aussi c'était une demande de
l'ufc que choisir donc ce qu'il faudra
bien surveiller quand même si les prix
d'ailleurs tout cela parce que
bon actuellement oseo restaurant vous
savez pas si c'est préparer maison oui
c'est du soleil qui réchauffe et met en
cause c'est à peu près les mêmes prix
bon là est ce que le fait de mentionner
que ces faits à la maison fera augmenter
les prix on verra faudra suivre tao mois
le consommateur et le client d'un
restaurant sera donné en fait maison il
saura que c'est des produits bruts qui
sont arrivés dans quelques arrêts
cuisine et la salle par le restaurateur
et ça ça va changer je pense pas mal de
donne aussi en tout cas
entre ce qu'ils font vraiment la cuisine
et ceux qui font plutôt de la cuisine
toutes faites quoi vous vous êtes donc
sa saison consommateurs quel type de
dossier vous instruisez en ce moment à
l'ufc que choisir région de versailles
c'est quoi la polémique du moment sur le
secteur la polémique du moment ainsi
vous les bons on a toujours
bouh dossiers qui concernent par exemple
l'énergie saisir les factures
électriques fekter
ce genre de chose oui c'est lui ce temps
puisqu'il verts étaient très longs donc
ça va et dans ce cas on a ça
régulièrement on a des sites dans le
domaine de l'assurance et dans une
banquière
déjà son groupe avait bien sûr tous les
contrats oui on tentera peut faire des
actions merci pato d'une ceinture une
dernière question des vacances il a
démarré au consommateur est évident sur
quoi en vacances et il doit être
vigilant surtout si part en vacances sur
la côte ou enfin en déplacement aussi à
ce que certains commerçants profitent
pas de la période de vacances pour
augmenter les prix
mais il faut poser des questions il faut
il faut se renseigner poser question il
comparaît donc en vacances il faut être
curieux tout moment de l'année sur les
changes y voilà enfin être un
consommateur acteur actif merci beaucoup